c'est un bon jour un break mondeville
merci de répondre à nos questions tôt ce
matin sur rtl france avant toute chose
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles
concernant l'état de santé de julian
assange en souvient un fin juin dans une
lettre publiée dans la revue britannique
de 27
une centaine de médecins dénoncé la
torture subie par le lancer en alerte
oui oui tout à fait merci le problème de
ceux ci médecin c'est qu'on n'arrive
même pas à avoir un accès en fait sa
propre personne mais de nouveau de
nombreux spécialistes en fait de la
torture ont confirmé le fait qu'il était
qu'ils étaient torturés et
vraisemblablement lendoye qu'on appelle
le baiser d'un ce qui expliquerait en
fait sont sont le fait qu' il ne cherche
ses mots qui ne se souvient même pas à
l'audience de son propre nom tout ça est
évidemment extrêmement inquiétant
d'autant plus qu' on ne l'a pas vu
physiquement depuis depuis fin février
en fait mais de parler d'audience
justement l'audience d'extradition est
prévue le 7 septembre et une expertise
abrite psychiatrique doit être rendu le
31 juillet avec la crise sanitaire qu'en
est il du calendrier judiciaire pour
julian assange
oui heureusement on a gagné à tous un
tout petit peu de temps le problème
c'est que concrètement vu son état de
santé déplorable et ce que disent les
médecins il n'est pas exclu qu'il meure
en prison
dans ces conditions d'ailleurs cette
espèce de pourquoi une expertise
psychiatrique dans le cadre d'une
extradition c'est complètement
il ya énormément de choses qui pose
problème dans la juridiction même
britannique et on comprend pas pourquoi
la défense et pas plus active et ne
porte pas plainte pour mauvais
traitements pour mauvaises conditions de
procédure il ya une seule plainte qui a
été déposée c'est la plate pour cause de
coded est alors que là le ce a laissé la
possibilité justement la justice
britannique de répondre sur le terrain
exclusivement à sanitaire s'est lui
donné en fait une porte de sortie
on comprend pas pourquoi il ya des
démarches ne sont pas
mais ce ne sont pas faites notamment
aussi pour appuyer par exemple la
demande qui est la plus la plus aboutie
kessel en fait du canton de genève pour
qu'elles aquila et transpartisane
multipartisane mais en même temps qui a
tout juste élu démocratique puisque le
grand canton de genève a voté pour la
possibilité de lui accorder un visa
humanitaire et donc de le lui donner le
temps en fait de tout simplement de se
soigner et ce qui donne une porte de
sortie honorable en tout cas moi
déshonorante pour le gouvernement
britannique dans ces conditions on ne
comprend pas pourquoi la défense ne
soutient pas cette démarche ne soutient
pas davantage en tout cas vous venez de
parler de la défense justement l'un des
avocats de julian assange c'est eric
dupond moretti qui a été récemment nommé
ministre de la justice en france
quel va être désormais son rôle au garde
des sceaux français est ce que paris
peut-il influencer dans ce dossier bah
écoutez ça fait partie des sujets qui
sont très peu abordée quand on parle de
monsieur dupont moretti qui pourtant est
un personnage très médiatique mais
effectivement il aurait beau jeu de dire
qu' il ya ses activités de ministre et
ses activités d'avocat qui sont quand
même assez assez différente mais bien
entendu qu'il faut qu'il faut le
questionner sur cette question à tout
moment mais je rappelle quand même que
monsieur dupont moretti ministre d'un
président qui n'a strictement rien fait
des parallèles qui suit cédait succéder
lui-même à françois hollande qui n'a
rien fait alors que je viens assange
avait révélé à quel point les présidents
français avait été espionnés a parlé pas
les états unis ça fait partie ça c'était
en 2015 fait partie des révélations
fracassantes de wikileaks mais pas pour
revenir un peu à ce que cet anniversaire
parce que vous disiez sur sur 2010 que
vous expliquer je crois qu'il faut aussi
mettre en balance avec ce qu'il a révélé
en 2016 parce que en 2010 d'une certaine
manière c'était ça renverser la table
parce que ça montrer à quel point les
guerres en irak et les guerrand la
guerre en irak et la guerre
d'afghanistan était absolument terrible
mais en même temps pour les gens qui
savent ce que c'est la guerre qui n'ont
pas la mémoire courte de certains
certains états unis je parle pas de tous
mais moins de certains qui n'ont pas
cette histoire pour mémoire courte
on s'attendait un petit peu ça ce genre
de guerre peuvent pas elles peuvent pas
être propre et d'une certaine manière
bien que ça a déclenché la vindicte des
états unis et puis des persécutions
qu'ils sont toujours en cours d'une
certaine manière ça le président obama
était dans une stratégie de désescalade
les deux retraits d'afghanistan de
devenir d'irak
et puis même des ventes est de fermer
guantanamo ce sont les révélations de
mais quelque part il s'en est servi en
revanche pas en 2016
au moment de l'élection présidentielle
il attaque complètement le camp
démocrate
parce que lui jenas ans et à sa
politique et de publier ce qu'il a ce
qui lui tombe sous la main
et quand la il révèle que madame clinton
est financé par l'arabie saoudite
au même titre que dajh face à dire que
l'arabie saoudite finances et la
fondation clinton et daher et que madame
clinton le sait sans compter le fait ce
que madame clinton en fait tu travailles
avec des réseaux soros pour organiser en
fait les mêmes campagne de changement de
régime
utilisé en ukraine mais cette fois
contre got donald trump et qu'elle ait
payé des millions par des banques
ça aussi c'est absolument fracassant et
mais ce que je voulais dire par là
justement fin juin on se souvient
washington à renforcer ses accusations
contre julian assange
est ce qu'il ya un lien avec tout ça et
à ce que justement son extradition est
inéluctable lorsque ce que je voulais
dire par là c'est que encore en 2010 on
pouvait dire qu'il est qu'il attaquait à
partir de la gauche américaine la gauche
dans son ensemble cette gauche qui qu'il
voulait détruire ce que faisait le camp
démocrate parce que par exemple à la
révélation notre collatéral parler de
quelque chose qui avait eu lieu trois
ans plus tôt en 2007 c'est à dire à
l'époque des bouches mais à partir de
2016 il s'est mis à dos et non seulement
la droite s'était déjà fermées y compris
la gauche et du cssa explique aussi ma
thèse c'est de dire qu'il est en danger
le départ parce qu'il me semble lâché
par tout le monde si vous voulez et même
les locaux qui est de désarmer viennoise
rodin qui a manifesté il ya quatre jours
là
elle est connue pour être une
une dame de la bad un vivienne westwood
elle s'est déguisée en canari dans une
cage devant la cour criminelle de
justice de londres c'est grâce à ce
genre d'événement qu'il est possible de
mobiliser l'opinion publique
mona mais le plus important c'est la
solution suisse c'est la plus légitime
c'est la plus aboutie c'est la plus
institutionnelle c'est la plus
démocratique et ça permet de changer de
lieu tout simplement il faut il faut
aussi dire à tous ces personnes
médiatique qui ne cesse de répéter une
sorte de storytelling c'est à dire d'un
discours qui est toujours un petit peu
conventionnelle sur la liberté
d'expression ne rentre un petit peu dans
les détails de la fère et d'appuyer un
peu ce qui se fait de concret et gérard
moretti c'est ce qui se passe en suisse
actuellement
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions et
bricmont ville je rappelle que vous êtes
éditeur et écrivain et auteur notamment
de l'ouvragé julian assange en danger de
mort aux éditions delga